we already took on dota 2 so you had to
know this was coming that's right
from playmaking supports too flashy
carries we are counting down the top 10
most important champions in competitive
league of legends with the fast and
furious play style Lucien has risen to
become the most important ad carry in
the games his high mechanical ceiling
separates good players from great ones
rewarding proper execution with
ridiculous DPS and mobility much like
being before him Lucien pushed the
boundaries of ad carry playing into a
new realm with the complexities of this
kit there is it going aggressive he gets
the killer baits eat candy take early
to escape to safety
amazing while he was first relevant as a
lane dominant pair Lucian has found a
home in the mid lane and even
occasionally the topless a strong pick
across multiple splits and one of the
flashiest champs in the game Lucia's
influence and flexibility cannot be
understated so much patient by this time
and he takes over Rika's has been a
highly influential piece is the first
year of competitive play remaining
relevant in multiple roles started his
life as a airburst Paige was dominating
the mid lane during season one and
season two the aggression the only great
unit wall the way back to the turret he
got some airtime on that one
cools gogo and down and faker with a
beautiful play by himself later the
utility of his ultimate and his arsenal
of disables helped him transition
smoothly to the top lane and jungle role
where he's been a highly stable pick for
many years
what does sake flash in the body slam
here comes quads as well
completely our first blood 30 microwave
you champion in the game have had such
longevity while others have come and
gone
Vegas has always found a place to sneak
back into the competitive meta sure his
play style has changed a lot over the
years but good ol Gragas is about as
reliable as they come again from Swift
incredible explosive cask few champions
have had as an immediate and dramatic
impact on the meta and professional
scene as rumbler his unique play
patterns changed the balance of the top
lane and his mid game power spike
shifted the dynamic of objective fights
giving him a profound impact upon just
about any game in which he's picked out
Eliza is in such a good position that
gonna read that took place that's innate
coming out since his early prominence
rumble has stuck around as a pocket pick
in the top lane and even the jungle and
the threat of a skilled rugby players in
costume approach pick bans in a totally
different way uses his just after a
fighter very low this is
forehead back look at Burt of our town
that Toby one is one Rumble emphasizes
proper mid gameplay rewards aggressively
and can turn the tide of the game with
the well-placed old they are doing it
it's Korean Korean
Nidalee has been played across multiple
roles including top mid and jungle since
season one and is a highly sought-after
pick whenever she's in the meta she
helps launch the careers of some of
league's first stars like hotshot GG
Stanley and later on faker will ambition
Baker just executes ambition in that mid
lane I figure however what makes her so
important is the variety of styles which
have worked for her
allowing Italy to remain relevant in
several roles across three years of
danger or so he thinks because here
comes spent scarran looking for - can he
find Rio as his cooldowns reset nope the
but double kill what is this Natalie
play from Spence carry her emphasis on
poke in the mid lane or the more
well-rounded pseudo assassin of the jump
it is Nidalee flexibility that has
shines they're gonna steal the way the
Bourbon is getting chuffed he has to be
careful to buy time because while Shen
has had lengthy periods of time where he
wasn't in the meta his importance of the
game comes for far more than his
popularity in fact while he's far from
the most dynamic or exciting pick on
this list
Shen pushed the macro game of League of
Legends forward and developed team play
and coordination in ways no other
champion has there it is be taken foe
here comes to Redemption the fights
gonna be breaking out in full
if Dawn's you gotta be kidding me
CLG with the farad steel darshan coming
up huge relateed as League developed
into a game with heavier emphasis on
proper map play and team coordination
rather than individual skills Shen was
the spearhead leading that change he's
trying to alter way comes outside
you can't kill seeds across his global
ultimate solidly me and fight defining
tongs pushed him into the upper echelon
of influential champion he's even found
a home pre and post rework in the
support role thanks to its flexibility
and ability to enable his teammates
there's no doubt Shen was instrumental
and bringing the competitive scene to
where it is today it's pretty tanky this
the flash kick his lemon Asians try to
pick this one up shadow dash comes out
another cue lands exhaust immediately
onto high the binding stalks my yellow
star gets through the face
stick
maybe rocket
[Applause]
to the left
he's trying to add to this one
[Applause]
contrary to her whimsical nature Loulou
has been one of the most reliable picks
across multiple rolls and meadows for
years she's jumped from support to mid
to top and more recently back to support
but always offers the same thing great
utilities shields peels and a good
amount of damage stole the burn much
like Nidalee and gragas it's Lulu's
flexibility in the inherent strength of
her kids that has helped her remain
relevant even through medicines and
nerves
insuk out of position gets out Oh does
it get out the lantern what a wild
growth from madlife an amazing flame
historically her popularity has gone
through peaks and valleys for when she's
strong Lulu is first picked first band
material she proved that the support
utility picks to find a home in the mid
lane leading to a more open pool of pigs
in the world for years even after she
left such as Carla unparalleled utility
flexibility and trail blazing a new
style of middling pigs
Lulu brings just about everything to the
table bloopers caught Dona Aurora but
pod destroys him with a double kill
bloopers going to die as well this is
going to be an ace for Edward gaming and
st. just beat masters 350 two and a half
minutes in that is the greatest Lulu
play I have ever received from his
release in 2012 through until the end of
2014
Zed was the defining champion of the mid
lane his damage and outplay potential
made him shine in the hands of some of
the brightest stars of the era including
bjergsen ryu and faker few assassins
have seen
handedly sheets a meta but said it did
just that as you're standing as a must
picker ban for the better part of two
years mark up the crates on kids is
gonna try and get any finishes it picks
up with overkill
Pharrell look at him it's a triple kill
Aaron a is gonna get take their Butte to
get the quarter quadric over psi-cops in
like Superman while he has fallen off
significantly he'll become a rarely
played pocket pick that doesn't really
affect sense and age considering this
historic dominators there's also an
intangible significance to that as
League was exploding in popularity in
2013 that was the face of the game what
a juke oh what a great play doing the
damage can he get out though and in the
hands of its most skilled players he
cultivated an image of League as a
dynamic and exciting spectators oh and
without price to clean it up for you oh
look at the class look at the boat
thank you well I was that Baker without
you I play the qss I can't actually what
Oriana is a champion that has been
wildly important even when she's not a
popular pick why because for years every
other middling champion has been judged
against her she is the gold standard for
any middling pick the baseline for
measuring the effectiveness of other
champions offering utility safely a
devastating to fight ultimate and more
she almost never falls fully out of the
meta as she offers so much as the
ability to every composition may be
irrelevant from season two all the way
for the panther he doesn't get it oh my
goodness the loons and to live it the
Penta kill could be really making the
moves happen for LGD well what makes
Orianna so special is her impact on so
many careers
any professional mid laner must have an
Orianna essentially she is the champion
by which their ability is done
no other champion says the same Miche
quite as well or as importantly as
Orianna thank your legions absolutely
devastates the ranks of kt rolster a
triple killer hem pod trying to get out
with his life but it just doesn't look
very likely unlike many of the other
picks on this list Thresh has reached
competitive success in only one role
however his influence on the growth of
the support position catapults him into
the rare company among the most
important champions of all time
you get to be that good fresh empowered
support players to a level of play
making they had never seen before
offering initiation disengage utility
and the ability to save priority carries
his dynamic impactful play style was a
step above the traditional support picks
of Sona Jana and Alistar and since his
release he has been a consistent if not
outright dominant champion he has rarely
ever fallen out of the medic was
standing the test of time in ways few
others have it doesn't hurt that some of
the Flash's support highlight is come
from six fresh hopefully bringing a
whole new meaning to the term playmaking
support chants come back one suck again
getting quite a bit
how does he
the sin is simply put the most important
league of Legends champion in its
competitive history while it took some
time for pro players to figure him out
high-level li simply pushed the
boundaries of what was possible on a
mechanical level he's been played tough
jungle and occasionally even mid
becoming a highly sought after pick from
seasoned kid offers nearly unparalleled
mobility a tremendous early and mid-game
presence initiation and utility his
dominance at his peak rivaled said his
utility put him in the same tier as
Thresh and his consistency made him
appear of Orianna much like Ariana for
mid laners he set a new bar for what was
expected of a jungler and it bears
repeating that Leeson changed the way we
think about mechanics at the pro level
it would be a disservice to name Leeson
anything other than number one on this
list
but he treats it back so now it's up to
rush through these alemana keyboard and
those were our picks now we're sure you
have a lot of thoughts on which
champions should and shouldn't have made
the list so let us know in the comment
section below thanks for watching if you
want more great content be sure to hit
that subscribe button